[Music]
and student becomes the teacher news oh
my favorite kind of movies submitted by
FBI surveillance van I need one of those
a student failed an assignment because
her professor believed Australia is not
a country what where is this in [ __ ]
High School or some [ __ ] no in a
university here in the US what is it
like University of Phoenix
it's called southern New Hampshire
University about the same oh okay so
what did they say it's not a country
it's a continent or it's not a
continents a country or the other way
yeah there's a professor was saying that
it's not a country at the continent
that's what the professor was saying so
because of that reason he failed
Ashley's assignment here and you know
what text not a country it's a continent
mm-hmm because the assignment was to
compare a Soviet people right so that's
what she had to tell the teacher that's
great her assignment was to compare a
social norm in the u.s. to another
country so she chose Australia but the
professor ended up just failing her
entire entire record here cuz you're
saying that it's a continent not a car
you study koalas in their social
structure so then this is why college
degree doesn't mean [ __ ] okay
yeah this is exactly why very sure this
rule probably has a PhD in order to
teach at a university right you have to
at least have a master's [ __ ] master
that'd be as tenure too because then you
can just slowly forget everything okay
while you teach why am I here it just
sounds like he's pissed because he
didn't give good instructions and then
now they kind of like save face yeah he
probably didn't want to compare to
Australia cause it's too close but then
really instead of actually examining the
contents of her paper should they're
just like that's not continent this was
his response in the email he said
Australia's is a continent not a country
that error made it nearly impossible for
you to accurately complete your week to
research outline correctly so I was well
I saw this news article recently where a
local news station was reporting on the
Olympics and on North Korea being Neil
in the Olympics and instead of
listing it as Pyongyang which is the
like the capital of North Korea
they said PF Changs Oh [ __ ] incredible
right that's the bet is that a joke
let's take a picture oh it was real I
saw it it was the picture was in the
article but it is fun it's like [ __ ]
like this I love it how would you do
that to that country specifically - why
not wash right walk that country you
know what's cool though they're joining
forces with South Korea I like that
that's really cool they definitely don't
have a dental care program in North
Korea no yeah I've been seeing them
smile - it's like Jake's just want to
help them out South Korea weather man
their munchkins bud yeah cuz of
malnourishment yeah they're gonna kill
it in like gymnastics or some [ __ ] cuz
there's so small
yeah right tumbling probably yeah maybe
limbo what's that weird Olympic sport
where you see this guy this slide yeah
what is that was thinking the same thing
and he's like do you know Carly Carly
Carly yeah that is the weirdest thing
I've ever seen in my life
it shouldn't be a sport any more hockey
know it could be considered there's a
shallow weird events there's one where
you're running around the track and they
purposely put like a big puddle of water
and you have to run through it to really
I don't know if it's called water
spritzer so that sounds like a JK the
funny thing is they let those things in
the Olympics but not skateboarding like
Turtles - I think is very silly looking
it's just hilarious looking to me like
watching them do that one-legged leap
thing over it I'm like I don't know what
this is anymore like this is a sport as
amazing that they have I think they put
b-boying in there not to know what does
it beep beep boys breakdancing yeah
breakdancing oh really that's in the
Olympics [ __ ] might as well be so
subjective Dan that's crazy
Wow and shot what's hilarious - like
that shit's hilarious look how you still
do it I never did it right it's
ridiculous looking it's just she put
some [ __ ] I'm like oh like art sweets
[ __ ] cool like that that's a skill
like that's cool chocolate is a skill oh
I throw that [ __ ] hella far it just
doesn't look that
isn't full we're just hating cuz we
never played those things where do you
see a big-ass like 300 pound dude like
get off his back I mean a lot of power
lifters or former shoppers and it
transfers over pretty good and then I
became a fan of shot pudding after I saw
how strong those guys are in the gym do
they have something else like shot put
where they put it on a sling and throw
it oh there's another event to their all
track event I forgot the camera karate
is in the Olympics now 2020 hey yeah my
cousin when he was in track he told me
that he was doing the shot put [ __ ] and
then he actually missed through it and
then he threw it at somebody running on
the track it took out his knee down Oh
Larry
why would he do up tonight my bad I
ruined your career my bad it was okay
because he got him at the the bending
joint so it just kind of been a collapse
so it didn't like snap any out but that
still sound it was hilarious dude I
would have it I would it being my own
Olympic event would be like okay we're
gonna watch as many movies as we can 24
hours and whoever falls asleep is that
like the gold medalist like could
[ __ ] stay up the longest or whatever
you know like that kind of [ __ ] either
stash is sleeping yeah oh yeah you watch
it's like the Joe's like oh I think the
judge would be asleep from watching no
the judges got a say what you just gotta
take shift is that yeah I'm surprised
like golf isn't like an Olympic sport is
it it's not craving your shed yeah it's
a pretty [ __ ] knock skillful [ __ ]
maybe it's hard if everybody clean and
do all that stuff that's why if you're
gonna bobsledding and shake you might as
well throw my throwing my movie selling
thing my movie thong thing oh yeah cuz
I'm just I just don't respect many of
the things that are in the Olympics I
think that's the biggest problem with
the radio they should have the [ __ ]
slap thing that they do or the guy puts
a heavenly song yeah that's so barbaric
dude but like even the breaststroke is
like it's like what the [ __ ] just swim
like efficiently to win like why do you
have to swim like that it's like what is
like what if we tie your legs together
many at this woman it's like you don't I
mean like well why does it let them swim
as hard as they can doesn't make sense
like if you're swimming just a fast
swimmer win right if you're running
don't put hurdles just the fastest
runner yeah yeah yeah instead of having
all of these like little division gets
cute you know like who can sprite with
the eye patch that
who cares is the fastest person wins
maybe they got bored and they had to add
some [ __ ] yeah when I got how do you
guys feel about speed walking then speed
walking is the most weight I want this
happening keep it cuz it looks
ridiculous
come on I think it's pretty dumb David
is even better
yeah it's just like yeah but their face
is so six like a cha cha yeah you know
it's so sad because when you watch it
televised and you see the audience it's
like two three people yeah you don't see
that many people and I'll just rest in
the legs
frankly it's like when you go to the
president's show at Disneyland or
whatever it's a hello my name but time
you get to like hello like my name is
[ __ ] John a John Quincy Adams I'm the
son of John Adams like okay it's time to
go come on guys
yeah that's that's why they had those
shows hundred percent at Disney that's
like the Jungle Cruise at Disney oh yeah
yeah well I like it too because the guys
are cuz the guys do dad jokes I got you
I like that one I wanted to get to see
that restaurant in the middle of the
lake that I don't know even how to get
there that's that's my favorite i legit
thought they really shot the animal with
the rifle oh I just like the monkey
sounds no that's crazy you actually
thought that that was a real animal yeah
I did I did I just know you know what it
is it's that I just thought that was
water than that that's a compliment I
thought that you were much smarter than
that see that's a compliment anyway yeah
the girl she had to teach her own
professor that Australia is both a
country and a continent did he finally
accept that [ __ ] douchebag ended up
changing her great ob+ he didn't want to
give her an a-minus he's like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] she called me out she got to [ __ ]
her over I would love to see him angry
like searcheth he's like what was
Australia that much confidence Oh [ __ ]
you're about to get schooled oh [ __ ]
well maybe he was just a liberal arts
teacher or something maybe he was he's
going first
yeah you know he's one of those majors
and I could say that because I was in
the socio but she typed departments up I
mean like even as a professor at that
point you can see like the due diligence
in the work and how it you know you know
to me like I would just pick them aside
it's like hey I'm gonna give you the
good grade but technically like that's
not really what I want it but I see what
you did you know I mean I mean you have
to have like some form of intelligence
to be able to communicate to your
student that as well you know I would
have the balls to be like listen I just
don't like you kid yeah I [ __ ] hate
you I don't like you I'm not gonna give
you good Griggs I don't like you and I
have power you don't what you gonna do
tell somebody I'll tell him you trying
to grab my ass okay kid wait weren't you
gonna be a teacher yeah I really want to
be is that one of the things that you're
gonna do I really want to be a teacher
don't [ __ ] get if you are the teacher
I would flunk on purpose I get you every
single year there you go see I know I'd
be that I'd be that tight teacher where
everyone's like man like I we have this
teacher mr. ball was like oh man mr.
ball was the man it's like hey did you
ever learn anything for mr. balls like
absolutely not nowhere
damn I'll be in trouble cuz I'll
probably [ __ ] all the teachers and then
like maybe even a hot student or
something as a teacher as a student I
worked at a university have sex with the
faculty the student is just a big sex
fest for me I can't be in I can't be a
college professor
we didn't you just say that you finally
[ __ ] your girlfriend like after it's
been a long time yeah so would you
slowly [ __ ] the faculty but what every
four years yep they could probably see
it coming in I have tenure and finally
in 20 years I banged every single
professor it's great
yep that's amazing
but the school here southern New
Hampshire University did say that they
replaced the professor Wow you got fire
that sucks
I mean you shouldn't get fired for being
a dumbass but I guess if you're a
teacher and by tangi daughter like he
realized the grade but he never
acknowledged his error like oh why too
much ego I hate those people man yeah
especially a teacher I think what do you
got to be proud about your teacher have
a student corrected me like really bad
what do you mean really bad you mean
like the ego true right yes okay I
couldn't really do anything for your the
teacher right because at that point if I
of a student like just check me so hard
in class I would bust up in tears
laughing at myself it's just so
hilarious right that's like two you get
a [ __ ] a B you passed the whole class
get the [ __ ] out of you I would explain
my thinking like you know what I thought
it was just like a big countryside I
don't know there's a [ __ ] government
people living there and Agia those
little animals but you might as well
just explaining it so everyone can have
a laugh at it yeah
[Music]